hi I'm Nick Gillespie with the reason
audio podcast today we are talking with
governor gary johnson he's the two-term
former governor of New Mexico who is
running for the Libertarian Party as
president to become president of the
United States governor thanks for
joining us absolutely thank you first
off we recently witnessed the second
presidential debate was there anything
noteworthy as far as you're concerned in
what transpired at the debate between
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton well I
think that they set new levels of
incivility clearly the first 30 minutes
went by where there was not one mention
of policy it was everything about not
voting for Trump it was everything about
not voting for Clinton well you have to
admit they they made pretty good cases
against each other didn't they I think
that they did yeah I'm in complete
agreement with both of them so talk a
little bit about how you would have
provided a different set of answers to
some of those key questions that I'll
run through them real quickly because
you know one of the things that you've
been pushing for is a libertarian party
candidate a third-party candidate who at
various points has been polling between
you know seven and ten percent or eleven
percent nationally what would you have
said about obamacare taxes spending
Syria and foreign policy that would have
added real substance to the debate do
you think well a small government that
really I am all about small government
myself and bill weld were not
wallflowers having served as governors
of our respective states New Mexico
Massachusetts heavily Democrat getting
reelected by being really over the top
fiscally conservative small government
neither one of us raise taxes a penny I
would have pointed out the certainty of
a Johnson weld White House that taxes
will not go up
we'll only go down but of course that
will be that would become entered upon
the legislature Congress passing that
legislation well can't talk about
spending as well because Trump said hey
I'm going to cut your taxes and Hillary
more or less acknowledge she's going to
raise them but you also in an official
response to the debate you said you know
part of trumps problem is that he would
cut taxes so far that debt would just
spiral out of control so how about
spending you'll keep taxes you'll hold
the line on taxes or cut them or and cut
them but what would you do with spending
well the certainty that spending won't
go up either now when I say spending
won't go up currently Medicaid and
Medicare are entitlements they're open
ended and so unless they are reformed
there won't there won't be controls on
spending but we're the only candidates
that are saying it's not an option to
not a reform to look at look at reforms
for Medicaid and Medicare it's not an
option to not look at reforming Social
Security it's not an option to say that
we're going to increase spending for the
military when in fact we should be
decreasing spending for the military
also that that not that that wouldn't
affect America's readiness or the
ability of this country to provide an
invincible national defense let's talk
about defense and foreign policy in just
a second but while we're talking about
entitlements what about Obamacare
Hillary Clinton in the debate said hey
you know what we're going to keep the
good parts we're going to get rid of
everything else which is an ever-growing
part of the program it seems based on
you know recent polls and surveys and
cost estimates Donald Trump basically
just said i will let people maybe you
know you know he said her plants
terrible my plan will be great what
would you do about
Obamacare and an insurance costs which
rank right up there with the economy for
you know what people are most concerned
about well I've always said and and it's
it's amazing to me II that Trump appears
as though he believes he's going to take
over the role of Santa Claus that there
are no constitutional limits to him
being president that he's going to
somehow wave a magic wand and he talks
about his magic wand and the fact that
he would repeal Obamacare well if I
could wave a magic wand I would repeal
Obamacare but I don't think that that's
going to happen but I do support a free
market approaches to health care
recognizing that a health care and free
market are about as far removed as they
possibly can be I'm always slain by
those that that look at insurance for
the reform of of our medical care when
in fact this should be about patients
this should be about doctors this should
be about the health care being provided
and this should be about government
taking a rule to genuinely blow the lid
off of competition that would be the
free market so what does what does that
mean specifically does that mean being
able to sell insurance policies you know
anywhere in the country kind of the way
auto insurers do does it mean getting
rid of occupational licensing or
restrictions on building out hospital
beds or medical facilities what you know
what what are you thinking about there
well let's do insurance I reject the
notion that we should have insurance to
cover ourselves for ongoing medical need
much like having car insurance a
catastrophic injury or illness we don't
have insurance on our cars to come on
going maintenance we don't have
insurance to cover our
calls for oil changes four flat tires
these are things that we pick up I think
having insurance to cover ourselves for
ongoing medical need would be much
analogous to having grocery insurance
something that doesn't exist imagine if
we had grocery insurance Nick going into
the grocery store first of all there'd
be no pricing on any of the shelves
because you and I have grocery insurance
that's mandated by the government why
would we buy hamburger when we could buy
filet well of course we're going to buy
filets so in a free market approach to
health care there wouldn't be insurance
to cover yourself or for ourselves for
ongoing medical needs so there would be
insurance to cover ourselves for
catastrophic injury and illness and if
we had a genuinely competitive blow the
lid off of competition for ongoing
medical need I'm going to guess that it
would cost one fifth of what it
currently costs but doctors would
benefit you and I as consumers would
benefit we'd pay less doctors would make
more because they didn't have to deal
with the bureaucracy of health insurance
I talked to a radiologist yesterday
after our excuse me two days ago after a
rally in New Mexico he says I'm a
radiologist he said and I have no idea
what my services get billed for you know
so what about one of one of the things
that you know many people even critics
of Obamacare say you know the saying
that insurers have to ensure everybody
that they can't say no you're too big of
a risk you know that guaranteed carry
clause I know that you're against an
individual mandate saying that you have
to buy insurance are you where do you
stand on that question of whether or not
insurers should be forced to take all
comers at capped costs well that that is
an issue that is out there and when you
recognize that
prior to this getting enacted and it may
in fact still be the case because it
hasn't the Affordable Health Care has
not been fully enacted but that is an
issue I think the government could have
undertaken but obviously that's a pool
that that that pool would be government
subsidized much like the health care
right now the Affordable Health Care Act
is is half of it i believe is government
subsidy at this point it just
discourages the government's constantly
drawing lines of eligibility and you as
a person in the work force us you and I
as citizens in this country where were
very cognizant of these lines of
eligibility and G do we go out and work
harder to make more money or gosh if we
make more money we're going to cross
over a line of eligibility so
productivity in a system that does not
reward going out and doing more that it
often times rewards you for just taking
a break rather than making more money
which is what so many heavy ever and
programs are that's the difference
between the two let's talk about Syria
specifically but foreign policy more
generally you had a couple of slip-ups
where you fail to identify Aleppo in a
conversation with Cable News host you
also kind of stumbled on talking about
foreign leaders in the world you know
the who's running north korea all of
that kind of stuff and this no and i
really take exception to stumbling on
foreign leaders that I admire here it is
what we eat Punk's after that yes go
ahead play I still can't identify later
that I really respect and then not being
able to name the leader of North Korea
the question was can you name me the
leader of North
yeah and I said you've got to be kidding
me really she goes yeah really I I can't
anyway well here's a question for you
about you know libertarians in general
small l capital l in the Libertarian
Party they're often seen as not either
not caring about foreign policy a lot or
not really knowing what they're talking
about how do you assure people and I
actually spoke with a millennial voters
who voted for you in 2012 doesn't
definitely it's not voting for Trump
doesn't want to vote for Hillary but he
said to me you know if Gary Johnson
needs to reassure me that he takes
foreign policy seriously and that he
knows what he's talking about what's a
you know how can you reassure people who
are in that position well that what
upsets me is is that because you have to
dot the i's and cross the t's on the
names of foreign leaders or geographic
locations that that somehow qualifies
you and I'm talking specifically now
about Hillary Clinton that that somehow
qualifies you to put our men and
servicewomen in harm's way end up dying
they end up hurt maimed psychologically
impacted for the rest of their lives and
that hundreds of thousands of innocent
people are dying in these conflicts
that's what upsets me so much about the
criteria to be able to dot i's cross the
t's and that gives you qualification
then to lead this country down the path
of putting everyone in harm's way our
military the people in these countries
that are so negatively impacted what is
your what is your capsule summary what's
your general approach to foreign policy
and how does it differ from what you
think Trump's is and what Hillary's
appears to be well the general approach
is skeptic that we need a skeptic in the
White House to actually
untangle all of what is happening I am
NOT receiving national security
briefings I would love to know and I'm
just assuming that a lot of promises
were made to the Free Syrian Army and if
they would offer opposition to Assad
that they would get us support of some
sort I'm just guessing here Nick but
skeptical and wanting to know wanting to
understand all of what the agreements
that have been made and by whom and how
do you go about unintentional line when
it comes to Syria that the only way out
of Syria is to join hands with Russia
diplomatically to make this happen and
to say anything otherwise is is is
living in Fairyland when Hillary Clinton
talks about creating safe zones safe
zones well what is that entail she says
no boots on the ground well that's also
not true if that means Special Forces
that still boots on the ground and when
it comes to safe zones well now we're
going to set up target areas for
Refugees but guess what it's not going
to be refugees that the Syrian army is
now going to bomb it's going to be under
the under the notion that this is where
the Free Syrian Army is hanging out
because it's a safe zone so what they
make sound what Hillary makes sound very
simple and a way going forward is just
is just this added added complexity to
what ultimately ends up to be a less
safe world not a more safe world in
recently after the Trump audio tape came
out where he's talking about effectively
are essentially assaulting women as his
one of his signature pick up moves so
tape that's 15 years old do you think
and you've come out with a sharply
worded statement about
that do you think that that kind of hot
mic incident and kind of blast from the
past is it relevant and what does it say
about Donald Trump in the Republican
Party that nominated him to be their
presidential candidate well I think it
is relevant and it's not 15 years old
it's it's 11 years old and I think he
Donald Trump himself has made the
statement over and over again that he's
not going to waver in what he does that
he's been the way he is for a long time
and that he will continue to be that
person so I look hypocrisy is the one
unforgivable saying one thing and doing
another I am NOT being a hypocrite in
saying I have never engaged in that kind
of conversation locker room conversation
certainly but locker room conversation
that in my opinion degrades women no I I
haven't partaken in that and I don't
think the majority of people do but for
those that do engage in that kind of
conversation I don't think that those
people should be aspiring or potentially
becoming president of the United States
in at the website red state your running
mate governor bill weld former governor
bill weld another two-term governor the
Republican governor of Massachusetts
invites Republicans who are disgusted by
Donald Trump to consider the Johnson
weld alternative he calls you honest
Gary Johnson a man without guile is that
accurate and is you know how do we know
that that there are not you know these
types of tapes and we'll talk about
Hillary's secret transcripts that have
come to light through WikiLeaks in a
second but how do we know that you're in
an honest man and a straight shooter
well of course that that a a rightful
question if you will
but in a way it's not a question mark
bill weld and I both we both served two
terms each in heavily Democrat States as
Republicans and we weren't wallflowers
so it's not so much a guess on the part
of Gary Johnson and is this the person
he says he is when you do have two terms
to look at having been governor and
myself personally I've always lived by
the credo that if you tell the truth you
don't have to remember anything if you
tell the truth you acknowledge mistakes
and that we all make mistakes but but
acknowledging them is there's no quicker
way to fix mistakes than acknowledging
them and I have always always believed
that the one unforgivable in life is
saying one thing and doing another bill
weld and I are not hypocrites and you
know what it's an open book subject to
scrutiny have at it you told
Albuquerque's KO eighty that you are
fielding immense interest from quote
dozens of Republican officials in such a
massive amount of quote that the
campaign can't even begin to deal with
it at the moment Republicans are you
know jumping off the sinking ship that
seems to be Donald Trump since this tape
came out he was already starting to
lutely I mean he was already behind in
the polls who are the people who are
contacting you are they talking about
endorsing you and can you name names are
there any high-level Republicans who
have said you know what governor Johnson
I think you're the best way forward I'm
going to I'm going to endorse you well I
think you've seen dozens that have come
out publicly and said they can no longer
support Donald Trump behind the scenes
yeah Gary Johnson bill weld your our
vote regard
uh endorsements Nick I firsthand
understand how difficult it's one thing
to say I'm not supporting the nominee of
your party which is really unprecedented
and I think all those names are pretty
well out there in the press right now
it's another end and I think by I don't
I don't think it's all that difficult
difficult to conjecture to recognize
that well where does their alternative
lie naming names regarding those
politicians that are considering
endorsing us and I have to believe that
many of them will i'm gonna i'm going to
protect the i'm going to protect the
innocent i don't i'm not going to put
anybody in a position of having to you
know to affirm or deny something that
i'm saying this is this is something
that they're going to have to come to
grips with and i do believe we are the
principled alternative what is the
biggest stumbling block for a
traditional Republican or a conventional
Republican a still registered Republican
from embracing the Johnson wealth
Libertarian Party ticket I mean you you
talk the small government the limited
government game that they say they're in
favor of so what you know what what's
holding more people back who are you
know from a Republican or you know
broadly right-wing or left-wing small
government perspective from just saying
hell let's let's go full libertarian
this time around well let me just let me
just ask the same question may be here
with a little louder volume what on
earth Republicans are you thinking
backing donald trump based on what he
has said forget about everything that he
said prior to four days ago but add to
it what he said four days ago you're
you're going to cease to be a party if
this is something that you're going to
continue to embrace so another form of
hypocrisy or at least you know a massive
difference between public and private
behavior came up during the debate
related to Hillary Clinton and the
WikiLeaks emails that were you know I
guess filched from her pinch from John
Podesta as account her campaign director
who was also the former chief of staff
of Bill Clinton started Center for
American Progress big lobbying firm as
well in DC in one of these transcripts
to a group in Brazil Hillary Clinton
seemed to be sore she said look it's
you've got private positions that you
talk about in settings like these in
speeches where there is no press there
are no outside people it might be a
group of donors or an interest group or
your fellow legislators you have one
position in private and you have another
position in public is that something is
that the way that politicians have to
play the game in order to get anything
done whereas that as hypocritical as
presenting yourself as a you know a kind
of family man who loves women in public
and then it's talking about grabbing
their crotches in private well I think
it's completely an analogous I say the
same things regardless of who the
audience is and in this case it's that
is really damning that's the worst about
politics saying one thing and doing
another look I'm representing you but I
have to say that I'm not necessarily
representing you the worst and that and
this is what Hillary Clinton is guilty
of that she knows best she's going to
try and tell you that she's working on
behalf of you when the reality is is
that she's working on behalf of her and
that's what I hate about politics that's
what I hate about politicians and this
is Hillary Clinton right here this
says it all do you think your approach
you know and your colleague your running
mate bill weld says you are without
guile which is oftentimes held as a
negative not just for politicians but
adults in general is you know is that
kind of openness and transparency would
would that help I mean we're we're in an
era where people have less and less
confidence in the ability of government
to do anything first off but then
especially that be honest or to act
honorably and things would you know are
you thinking that you disagree with a
lot of Bernie Sanders supporters on
stances on some things you're right
there with them in terms of civil
liberties and foreign policy for the
most part but in other ways you know
they dislike your economic policy or
your economic freedom policy but do you
think this will appeal to disgruntled
Democrats who are like you know what I
don't want to play that game anymore I
want a guy who's a straight shooter even
if I disagree with them well I hope it
appeals to everybody that's what I hope
and based on my experience in my life it
is appealing and if this whole thing
ends up short because we are honest we
do tell the truth and in that context
Nick that's you know that's these golf's
if you want to call them golf's the fact
that I subject myself and I'm this is
not an excuse but here's the reality I
subject myself to six hours of
interviews every single day there's no
there's no questions that are
pre-written there's no there's no
anticipation of what's going to get
asked and in that context do you know
everything no you don't aleppo gosh how
about Syria the Syrian city of Aleppo
what should we oh my gosh of course
Syrian
city Aleppo Aleppo though for me well
Aleppo I'm thinking acronym and I'm not
trying to make an excuse here ninety
percent of Americans don't know what
Aleppo is but ninety percent of
Americans aren't running for president
of the United States either so no excuse
son on anything anything's fair but fair
is saying the same things in front of
the same in front of regardless of the
group when Bernie Sanders supporters
stand up and say hey I'm opposed to to
TPP because it's all about crony
capitalism you know what there might be
some elements in there that are a crony
capitalist extend on to defend why it
makes things better look III do believe
crony capitalism is alive and well crony
capitalism is when the government picks
winners and losers free market by
definition is devoid of government
interference talk a little bit about why
would Hillary Clinton you know one of
the things that's amazing about all of
this is that is that what she was saying
in secret was that she believed in a
hemispheric free trade zone with open
borders movement free movement of people
goods and services of knowledge of
culture which sounds pretty libertarian
to me and I know you know you're the
only candidate out of the four
candidates with any national reach
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump Jill Stein
and you you're the only one who is not
protectionist when it comes to when it
comes to trade and you're also the only
one who is actually envisioning a world
in which people are free or to cross
borders rather than less free to do that
why would Hillary Clinton be ashamed of
being a free trader why would you be
afraid of allowing people from poor
countries to move to wealthy countries
and from people from wealthy countries
being able to invest in travel to and
trade with poor countries well that's
what would be wonderful to
have a debate made up of with Nicholas
is the moderator in a debate and you can
probably get me a point point being
there's some real differences between
the candidates and to be able to point
out these differences and just have a
very civil debate and discussion on the
issues as opposed to he [ __ ] he said she
said and it sounds more like divorce
court as opposed to what a debate and a
discussion should be about these issues
when you when you look at big government
versus small government when you look at
civil liberties when you look at drug
policy they have not yet once talked
about the legalization of marijuana do
they support it don't they support it
which makes you think that there are
some pre submitted questions to all this
we have the highest incarceration rate
of any country in the world why is that
the case blah lives matter the
skepticism regarding our military
interventions Hillary support of arming
the Free Syrian Army probably
recognizing that those arms were going
to end up in the hands of the Islamists
in the hands of Isis and yes free trade
and immigration which Donald Trump's to
be hung on that beautiful wall that he's
going to build across the border who who
is on your shortlist for key cabinet
positions obviously bill weld is a vice
president you've talked openly about how
you guys would be running a lot of
things in concert with one another but
who's who are you thinking about for
attorney general for Secretary of
Treasury defense and state you know I've
always been well served and I've gotten
into trouble in this campaign kind of
violating what I've always said that
that I'm about and that is I'm not
predisposed to anybody come apply I'm
going
hire the best the brightest and in that
context having served as governor of New
Mexico I was just blown away by how many
people by how many qualified people came
and applied for the jobs in New Mexico
government saying that philosophically
they aligned with me that they were
going to make my agenda happen which is
really all about smaller government best
product best service lowest price I have
a feeling that if you take the
Department of Defense as an example i
have a feeling there will probably be a
line a city block long with those with
individuals qualified individuals that
would stand up and and and and receive
the appointment of being Secretary of
Defense that would say yeah we can cut
the defense we can cut defense spending
by twenty percent here's how we can do
it here's my experience and we will have
a national defense second to none that
it will be invincible and here's how we
move forward that's so so you would you
would lay out here's the broad objective
for defense we want to cut spending
significantly without reducing the
ability of the department to do what
it's supposed to do which is provide
safety and security to the American
people and territory and then you would
interview people to get out of
fulfillment and in the case of having
been governor I did have they were there
was a screening process a number of
people half a dozen people that I had
screening who I finally interviewed but
I interviewed everyone for every one of
these positions and like I say it was it
was a wonderful process and i would have
that same process as president unite
safe look come apply there there's
there's no pre
positions that have been have been
promised ahead of time nobody's been
promised a job in this administration
there are recent polls by Gallup and
others for a long time Americans wanted
divided government and it seemed to be a
kind of way of minimizing or moderating
the extremes in you know whether it's an
extreme towards a Republican vision of
government or democratic government but
you know we keep getting with brief
instances in between over the past 20 or
so years we'll have a Democratic
president and Republican Congress a
democratic republican president a
Democratic Congress etc how how would a
weld how would a Johnson weld
administration create unity since you
would have absolutely nobody in Congress
who is from I you know from your party
and in any way shape or form well how
about how about the term civility that
civility returned to all this that yes
you can have a varied opinion but right
now Republicans want to kill Democrats
and vice versa Democrats are looking to
kill Republicans does anybody believe
that the polarity in Congress is going
to get any better given an election of a
trump or Clinton know it's going to be
further from that well put a couple of
guys Johnson weld right down the big
six-lane highway middle of all this
fiscally conservative socially inclusive
skeptical about our military inventions
free trade you know what you can link up
with a little bit of that on either side
of the aisle and maybe actually get
things done so that's the pitch is hey
you can have disagreements but let's
just do it civilly and there's a whole
bunch of stuff that both sides of the
aisle could come together with if you
actually had what I'll call an arbiter
in chief as opposed to a continuation of
the polarity that is there what would be
the number one legislative priority in a
Johnson camp you know you you get
elected what the first day of work what
is what's at the top of your to-do list
it's to submit a balanced budget to
Congress so in the first 100 days we're
pledging to submit a balanced budget to
Congress which is very encompass ngoni
speak volumes to to defense policy
that's going to speak volumes when it
comes to healthcare Medicaid and
Medicare that's going to speak volumes
as to the being able to sustain Social
Security into the future it's what it
covers a whole lot of bases when you
start talking about a balanced budget
what are the key things that you're
planning on doing between now and
Election Day to get more votes to get
more visibility to get more influence do
you have any October surprises of your
own up your sleep no surprises but we're
we're nimble and taking advantage of
really invitations that do come pretty
darn spur of the moment so to have the
flexibility to respond to those
invitations that's that's where we're at
right now all right well we will leave
it there we have been talking with
governor gary johnson he's the former
two-term head of the New Mexico
government as a Republican he's running
for president on the Libertarian Party
ticket governor thanks for talking to
reason Nick thank you very much and
we'll talk to you later you bet all
right for reasons podcast I'm Nick
Gillespie look us up at iTunes
soundcloud reason.com youtube / reason
TV and go to reason.com / podcasts for
every possible feed you could want to
stick your status thanks so much all
right thank you